also man kommt sich irgendwie schon
leicht komisch vor die ganze zeit mit
diesem wasserflaschen unterm arm die
größe heraus oder daran ist wirklich
dass man dauernd aufs klo muss ja und
jetzt auf dieses video es hat spaß
gemacht
trinkt viel wasser wasser ist gesund als
ich habe mich wirklich eigentlich in
meiner eigenen einschätzung deutlich
übertroffen
hey leute was glaubt ihr jetzt
willkommen beim neuen video ja doch ich
hoffe natürlich geht's gut ja ich setze
in den letzten tagen gefühlt fast nur
noch hier in meinem schreibtisch weil
ich wirklich so viel lernen muss also
ich hab ja eigentlich nur meinen laptop
mein handy und auch jede menge lernstoff
halt ich kann euch das hier mal kurz
zeigen
ich habe wirklich kann man das ding ist
ich studiere medien management nennt
sich das über kommunikations management
und erstmal so denkt man sich ja cool
hat bestimmt viel mit medien zu tun
medienrecht arbeitsgesetz recht
bürgerliches recht aktiengesetz und das
fehlen noch zwei bücher wo sind wir denn
jetzt und dann auch das
handelsgesetzbuch einfach fünf fette
bücher für irgendwelche rechts fächer
also ich sag mal so ich bin jetzt zwar
nicht der dümmste aber es ist schon
schwer
also das muss man ganz offen und ehrlich
sagen darum soll es heute aber
eigentlich auch gar nicht gehen ist ja
klar ich war gestern natürlich ich bin
nebenbei mal so ein bisschen hier am
laptop unterwegs und ich hab so ein
video gefunden
da ging es darum das war ein beitrag vom
frühstücksfernsehen und 2 spielt sagen
wir schauen wir mal kurz rein ich will
eigentlich gar nichts aus dem video
zeigen weil nach sperren ihr das oder so
kein plan so auf jeden fall kann man das
hier sehen fürs überleben 20 liter
wasser am tag
ist halt ein videobeitrag ich habe mir
das gestern mal in ruhe angucken und da
geht es halt um so einen typen sehr wohl
die krankheit hat und der körper
verliert ultraschnell wasser und
deswegen muss er wirklich das ist
überlebenswichtig 20 liter wasser am tag
trinken ich meine 20 liter
das ist echt ne menge ich glaube mein
rekord liegt so bei 5 liter ich hatte
meinem urlaub so einen sonnenstich und
musste halt wirklich viel trinken damit
dass weggeht ich meine da habe ich
glaube ich so 5 liter gedrückt und das
war schon echt eine menge man sagt ja
immer viel trinken ist sehr sehr wichtig
so ich glaube ich trinke auch vor allem
jetzt hier im winter viel zu wenig also
man sollte irgendwie an einem tag so
einer halb zwei liter trinken oder so
wobei inhalt zu viel wasser auch wieder
ungesund ist was ich jetzt erstmal hier
bei dem typen sagen muss wenn man hier
so kommentare liest um mein gott so
schlimm das will ich nicht haben der
arme wem tut mir auch leid sehr ich
könnte das nicht aushalten das gleiche
problem bei ihr mit schokolade
die krankheit ist gar nicht so selten
andere brauchen halt nur alkohol anstatt
wird erstmal was ich dazu sagen muss
also ich gehe eigentlich an all solche
beiträge relativ kritisch dran weil
keine ahnung wenn man hier so sieht eric
25 lebt seit fünf monaten im zug das war
so ein typ der sich halt einfach die
bahncard 100 kauft das heißt er kann
so oft wie er will erste klasse im zug
fahren auch in meinem zu essen und so
weiter und ich denke mir so als wenn es
menschen gibt die das machen deswegen
würde ich jetzt hier sagen wenn er
wirklich so eine krankheit hat tut mir
natürlich sehr leid allerdings wollte
jetzt erst mal nachschauen ob es
wirklich so eine krankheit gibt so ich
habe jetzt hier mal gegoogelt
mukoviszidose unheilbare erbkrankheit
ist eine der häufigsten
das ist was anderes keine ahnung also
ich weiß jetzt auch nicht wonach ich da
suchen soll
20 liter hier sind halt überall beiträge
über den aber wie die krankheit jetzt
genau heißt steht auch nicht also ich
glaube dass jetzt erst mal aber ich kann
euch auch nicht zu 100 prozent
versichern ob es das wirklich gibt aber
wie gesagt wird das stimmt natürlich
sehr leid will natürlich niemand mit
tauschen so ich habe jetzt einfach mal
für das heutige video überlegt weil es
mich halt wirklich interessiert ja wie
viel wasser kann ich an einem tag
trinken also ist dann irgendwann einfach
stopp oder wie viel schafft man so meine
ich bin jetzt auch ich der größte oder
breiteste ich bin ungefähr so 1 80 groß
und wird jetzt eigentlich mal versuchen
so zehn liter zu trinken und keine
ahnung ich meine ich muss eh fast den
ganzen tag hier sitzt und lernt dann
kann ich auch nebenbei wasser trinken
und das einfach mal so ein bisschen
dokumentiert dann habe ich gleichzeitig
auch ein cooles video für euch meinen
das interessiert der bestimmt viele von
euch auch ihr könnt ja mal an dieser
stelle und in die kommentare schreiben
das war wohl neuer rekord an wasser
trinken am tag ich probiere einfach mal
wieviele schaffe ich habe eben was er
eingekauft was ihr aber auf jeden fall
nach gucken wollte ob das wirklich so
gesund ist jetzt einfach mal 5 678 liter
zu trinken also google ist dein freund
nach wie viel liter wasser ist ungesund
so gut wie viel wasser ist so wenig zu
viel
man kann das nicht einfach stehen keine
frage nur trinken ist wichtig und wir
sind aber wie viel ist genügend
jahrelang kursiert das gefährliche
gerücht es sei niemals zu viel wasser
dieser irrtum kann zu einer tödlichen
wasser vergiftung führen also leute spaß
damit nicht rum macht es auf keinen fall
da am besten
logisch wasser ist lebenswichtig
schließlich besteht jede einzelne
körperzelle zum größten teil aus dem
klaren dass die chemische summen formel
hat so trägt wir hören ist von unseren
müttern und lesen ist in zeitschriften
trinkt mehr wasser
man kann gar nicht genug wasser trinken
und das stimmt ja auch ohne wasser
könnten wir nicht überleben
viele menschen wissen aber nicht dass
man sehr wohl zu viel wasser trinken
kann
es kommt zwar selbst vor an einer
vergiftung kann man sogar sterben sieben
bis zehn liter flüssigkeit am tag können
erheblichen schaden anrichten also leute
das ist ganz wichtig setzt euch jetzt
nicht zu hause hin und versucht das
nachzumachen und wenn wir haben da hat
man mittag ich werde später natürlich
auch ins essen zwischendurch und so
weiter aber ich würde einfach mal
versuchen so ein bisschen was dazu
trinken und mal gucken wie es mir dabei
so geht ob ich dann extrem fit bin oder
nicht also ich nehme ich so ein bisschen
mit über den tag aber ich werde auf
keinen fall übertreiben also ich denke
jetzt nicht dass ich die sieben liter
schaffe oder so will ich auch gar nicht
weil dieser beitrag macht mir schon so
einige gedanken aber wir werden einfach
mal gucken und ja wir sehen also häufig
keine space und an dieser stelle ich
habe jetzt zwölf liter wasser habe ich
eben getauft was ich mich aber auch so
frage jetzt der typ der diese kein geld
hat er trinkt er wirklich dann jeden tag
20 liter warum das nicht gefährlich wird
weiß ich auch nicht so also wie tell
sponsert mich bitte danke schön für das
nächste video ist echt viel das sind
gerade mal zwei liter also der typ in
dem video trinkt anscheinend zehnmal
diese flasche finde ich schon krass ich
würde einfach mal versuchen jetzt ein
bisschen was daraus zu trinken ja wie
gesagt jetzt gerade es mittag muss
später noch in die uni danach wollte ich
was essen und ich will jetzt eigentlich
mal gar keine zahl sagen wieso oder was
ich denke was ich schaffe ich werde das
hier merken ob sie dann gut geht oder er
nicht und dann halt auch aber meiner
meinung nach so 5 liter schaffe ich
locker habe ich auch schon öfter mal
natürlich muss ich auch wahrscheinlich
dann alle zehn minuten wissen ja ich bin
mal gespannt
um ehrlich zu sein ich glaube es ist
auch ein bisschen blöd dass im winter zu
machen weil es einfach nicht heiß ist
und der körper sowieso kaum schweiz also
man gibt ja kaum flüssigkeit wieder
arbeit hat ja auch im winter fast nie du
bist so wirklich also ich versuche das
jetzt einfach mal in der nächsten halben
stunde leer zu trinken und dann möchte
ich mich einfach mal spiel sagen wir
sehen uns leichter so 400 milliliter
sollten das jetzt schon sein aber noch
mal an dieser stelle trinkt auf keinen
fall mehr als sieben bis zehn liter das
kann scheint echt gefährlich werden auch
wenn ich das selber auch gar nicht so
wusste er besonders gleich ich lerne
jetzt ein bisschen peace so leute wäre
es mittlerweile schon 17 oder so ich
muss jetzt auf jeden fall los in die uni
ich hab echt angefangen und das war ich
habe mir das irgendwie leichter
vorgestellt ich mein wasser trinkt sich
eigentlich so einfach nur ich hab bis
jetzt wirklich erst einmal diese flasche
komplett geschafft und hier ist so
ungefähr noch die hälfte drin also in
drei oder vier stunden 3 liter aber das
ist ja eigentlich egal an sich geht es
mit top bevor jetzt los und mal sehen
vielleicht schaffe ich das einfach mal
so auf mich zukommen und wir stellen uns
gleich wieder
ich finde ich sehe mir diese woche zeigt
immer aus wie so ein schulkind auf jeden
fall habe ich immer die man ungefähr
zwei oder drei hinter dabei die größte
herausforderung daran ist wirklich dass
man dauernd aufs klo muss schreibt mal
in die kommentare ob ihr die neuen
release cool findet oder nicht ich war
mal wieder so ein glückspilz und habe
die bekommen auch so und das war
natürlich nicht die die verlost wurden
weil die kam erst danach haus die ich
jetzt gerade anderen nur damit ist keine
frage kommen und ich hole mir das noch
eine kleinigkeit zu essen dann hoffe ich
komme ich pünktlich werden sehen so
leute ich hab mir grad noch was zu essen
sowohl ich hab hunger
ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt am wasser
lag es dass es nun ich muss los bis
gleich
solange ich bin jetzt da ich muss aufs
klo
aber wir sehen uns gleich wieder ich
würde sagen hier als erstmal nur ein
bisschen weiter lernen mein ganzes leben
steht wie es nur noch ums lernen gerade
ja alles über vielleicht dauert
geschafft
also leute werden ungelogen samstag 1959
ich weiß auch nicht warum ich noch hier
bin aber okay war pechstein ich habe
jetzt schon insgesamt er wird das ist
jetzt nicht ganz die hälfte aber fast 5
liter getrunken und ich finde wenn man
wirklich so drauf achtet alle zehn
minuten was zu trinken
es ist auch voll einfach also ich bin
halt wirklich top wird ich habe wirklich
energie zu grabe
hunger habe ich nicht wir haben
samstagabend
ich finde das so heftig dass ich bis
jetzt einfach gelernt habe hätte ich
früher nie gemacht
naja also man konnte ich irgendwie schon
leicht komisch war die ganze zeit in
diesem wasser löscht unterm arm
so leute also wir haben jetzt die hier
und die hinten auch schon leer also das
sind jeweils das sind 4 liter und bei
der hier hat ungefähr die hälfte also 5
liter und wir haben jetzt 20 nach acht
grad mal also ich hab noch ein bisschen
es ist alles echt entspannt ich versuche
jetzt einfach mal noch viel zu trinken
wobei ich bin topfit und wenn ich dann
jetzt schon video mache kann ich mich
anstrengen ich habe jetzt auch wirklich
noch mal nachgeguckt und ich habe die
krankheit gefunden sie heißt diabetes
den sie pius ich blende das hier mal
kurz ein der diabetes in sie videos
blablabla habe auch kein mensch und so
weiter ist eine angeborene oder
erworbene krankheit die durch eine
vermehrte ruine ausscheidung und ein
gesteigertes durstgefühl mit vermehrten
trinken charakterisiert uns ja also das
scheint wirklich zugeben finde ich echt
krass die man jeden tag wirklich darauf
achten zu müssen dass man die ganze zeit
was drehen wir die alle zehn minuten ich
achte auch darauf dass ich andauernd
wasser trinke stelle ich mir schon
anstrengend und nervig vor muss man sich
auf jeden fall echt dran gewöhnen
an solchen stellen bin ich dann mal
ziemlich froh dass ich komplett gesund
bin wir sehen was gleich wieder ich weiß
nicht was wir noch mal ich kann jetzt
eigentlich anfang dieses video zu
schneiden
mal sehen wie es gleich so leute
ziemlich coole kameraposition ja ich
habe mir gerade was zu essen da machen
wir haben jetzt 10 uhr ich wollte jetzt
den anschlüssen ein bisschen selber
hauptmann sich geben jetzt noch mal
wirklich gas und ich bin mal gespannt
wie gesagt schreibt neuer rekord in die
kommentare
aber ich muss jetzt auf jeden fall
erstmal wieder was essen über mich
gehört das iphone bald gehört das
irgendwie von euch so damit hier nicht
wieder die kommentare auf gmail du hast
das ganze wasser besteht weg gekriegt
hab irgendwann letzten typen getroffen
er hat zu mir gesagt ja alex bei deinem
pizza video
du hast doch locker edi pizza
weggeschmissen immer ich dachte ich bin
ich pizza wegschmeißen weil wasser kann
man es ja noch verstehen aber trotzdem
ich mache jetzt mal kurz die sechs liter
voll
das muss echt sagen das ist so einfach
der kletter und ich fühle mich gut ich
bin richtig motiviert irgendwas zu
machen gerade zwölf sekunden später also
es ist gerade männer plötzlich
willkommen dass man plötzlich so einen
druck im bauch hat aber ich denke man
dass hier gleich so leute ich bin jetzt
gerade hier bei der vierte flasche
ich komme mittlerweile auch ein bisschen
auch nicht vor aber ich kann dann
immerhin sagen ich habe schon mal an
einem tag acht liter wasser getrunken
das ding ist halt wenn man wirklich viel
wasser am stück trinkt sag mal du
trinkst jetzt ein liter innerhalb von
weiß nicht eineinhalb minuten dann tut
das schon weh im bauch als man merkte
dass man das halt irgendwie verteilt
dann ist es überhaupt kein problem
jetzt mal ohne spaß ich zähle jetzt so
viele flaschen halt sagen wir mal das
sind insgesamt acht liter und ich war
wirklich gar nicht so ob kissel
um ehrlich zu sein weiß ich gar nicht wo
das ganze wasser hin ist ich hätte es
wirklich deutlich schwerer erwartet
würde ich den tag so ein bisschen anders
planen würde ich vielleicht morgens um
acht uhr anschauen ohne witz ich könnt
euch versprechen ich würde locker über
zehn meter schaffen
aber das wollen wir ja gar nicht
versuchen weil eventuell ist das ja
wirklich nicht so gut für die gesundheit
deswegen noch mal an dieser stelle
heute trinkt am besten nicht mehr als
fünf liter am tag ich weiß nicht
vielleicht hab ich ja auch irgendeinen
syndromen dass ich viel wasser brauche
ich hab's tragende stunde fahren und
gucken ob wir haben jetzt hier noch so
viel ich kann euch eigentlich jetzt
wieder zeigen dass ich das innerhalb von
zwei minuten easy weg kriege am besten
diese menschen die so 8 liter auf einmal
kriegen dann sowohl das spucken können
so hindert bin ich glaube ich auch
also ich könnte euch jetzt versichern
will ich mir eine halbe stunde warten
dann könnte ich eigentlich wieder
genauso viel trinken nur jetzt gerade
ist echt wieder kritisch ja und jetzt
auf dieses video es hat spaß gemacht
bringt viel wasser wasser ist gesund vor
allem das wasser von vittel hammergeil
trägt nicht zu viel trinkt mindestens
ein liter am tag und dann uranmetall
water day keeps the doctor away
also ich hab nicht wirklich eigentlich
in meiner eigenen einschätzung deutlich
übertroffen ich habe gedacht vielleicht
ist schon bei 6 7 liter woher das heißt
deutlich auf jeden fall habe ich gedacht
weil 6 liter sollte schluss sein mehr
schafft sollte yanagida geschafft und
wir haben jetzt wirklich punktgenau
gleich 24 uhr das heißt in zwölf stunden
das heißt in 12 stunden 8 liter wasser
okay ist eigentlich nur vor dem ziel
fährt will ich muss sagen das hat mit
dem video
ich hoffe es hat euch gefallen wie
gesagt macht das am besten nicht zu
hause nach viel wasser am tag sagt alla
mamma mia hat gesagt ich muss viel
wasser trinken aber nicht zu viel gas
natural zagora platz nach oben da für
die acht liter und wir sehen uns dann
die tage wieder
ich muss jetzt natürlich ein bisschen
werden sind doch einige bücher haut rein